comment s'appelle l'oncle de frédéric
mitterrand donc je ne sais pas le nom
d'un mitterrand forcément mais ce retour
dont mitterrand allez-y c'est tout
mitterrand sans prénom je ne sais pas
l'oncle de frédéric mitterrand ou madame
l'oncle de frédéric mitterrand s'il ya
un piège autre histoire mais je ne
trouve pas messieurs comment s'appelle
longue de frédéric mitterrand et b selon
que frédéric mitterrand et choco qui
sert généralement non le jeune acteur
alors de quoi je vous dis je
je disais je suis je serais tenter de
vous répondre françois mitterrand mais
je suis sûr que c'est pas ça fait quoi
je ne sais pas mais je sais c'est très
facile
charb hier
on s'appelle françois mettant c'est le
président de la république mais vous
mêlez de l'ombre de messi mythe et la
sépaq et vétérans
tu m'en veux pas maîtrisé mais les
corrections de ne rien rater de l'ina
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux